ali messika bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors les
parlementaires israéliens ont donc
rejeté très tôt ce matin ce projet de
compromis sur le budget de l'état
expliquez-nous pourquoi les chances
d'une dissolution du parlement et la
convocation de nouvelles élections se
rapproche
hamiti normalement la knesset se
dissoudra ce dissolvera je sais pas
quand on dit d'ailleurs de manière
automatique
donc c'est parce que votre reportage ici
mon avis il a été fait hier soir juste
avant le vote donc le vote a été
entérinée 47 49 voix contre 47 c'est à
dire qu'il ya eu un peu moins de deux
tiers des d'un tiers des parlementaires
qui n'ont pas voté
d'accord donc sur 120 il ya 96 votants
et sur les 96 donc a été voté donc la
notion contre c'est à dire qu'en fait
ils sont contre la la la la
chara c'est à dire la la réconciliation
des points de vue et donc on va
forcément aller vers des élections
c'est à dire qu'en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est que les deux chefs de partis
aussi bien bebig ans que que binyamin
netanyahou ont été si vous voulez mis en
minorité à l'intérieur de leur parti ce
qui fait que il ya une certaine saveur
de personnes qui se sont abstenus qui
rejoint volontairement pas voulu venir
dont 24 députés sur 120 est donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans la
situation où le budget ne passera par le
budget ne sera pas voté le budget ne
tend pas voter la knesset se dissoudra
de manière automatique
aujourd'hui donc on va aux élections le
23 mars
donc là aujourd'hui c'est sur c'est à
dire que dans les prochaines heures il
peut pas y avoir un éventuel accord qui
pourrait se trouver
c'est impossible puisque il ya deux
votes hier soir
jusqu'à 2h 3h du matin et que enfin je
vois je vois pas comment ça serait
possible effectivement de réconcilier
aujourd'hui les des points de vue et de
ne pas dissoudre la knesset la knesset
va forcément se dissoudre et il va
forcément y avoir des élections le 23
mars
et pourquoi c'est cette question du
budget précisément qui est insoluble
alors c'est pas exactement la question
du budget qui est insoluble
le budget effectivement c'est
représentatif de la politique de l'état
ça c'est très très important mais ce qui
est le plus problématique c'est le fait
que j ai à l'intérieur de blanc bleu qui
représente plus grand chose en réalité
petit israélienne il y à un certain
nombre de ministres qui ont été nommés
et le ministre qui dérange le plus c'est
effectivement la coalition
gouvernementale c'est à dire le likoud
et binyamin netanyahou
c'est effectivement la nomination en
tout cas on devrait le fait que le
ministre de la justice qui est ni ciel
coréen est un opposant virulent
minelli netanyahu et que ça dérange
énormément
le premier ministre qu'il y ait en la
ministre de la justice qui est
totalement totalement destinée à essayer
de destituer et donc il désire que ce
soit quelqu'un d'autre qui soit nommé à
sa place et donc simulait de le le parti
blanc bleu a pris a voulu avec bing en
ce cas à mon avis si votre avis je suis
pas chaud mais sa dernière carte
politique qui va disparaître
à mon avis de la vie politique c'est non
non mon temps quand les quelques années
qui viennent on peut jamais dire jamais
mais à mon avis ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui
salut apporté à un très bon registre
donc aujourd'hui il est impossible pour
la knesset à mon avis de ne pas se
dissout est ce que ça veut dire que la
perspective de ces nouvelles élections
finalement elle profiterait plus à
benyamin nétanyahou écoutez ici on y
serait ça commençait vraiment très
compliqué même pour les isréliens de
comprendre ce qui est en train de se
passer
il ya des désistements par exemple qui
donne sa requête à 1 min ce qui a été
toujours likoud et un membre du likoud
éminents qui s'est séparé comme une fin
du likoud qui recense tout ça ça
ressemble un peu à une sorte d'implosion
aussi tu du début du grand parti steiner
le likoud mais c'est pas exactement là
on peut pas prédire et effectivement que
ce que le likoud va reposer parce qu'il
a subi d'autres d'autres revers pendant
pour notre son histoire ce qui encore
une fois ce que moi je pense c'est qui
vaille énergie forcément un moment à une
sorte d'homme providentiel qui va
arriver dont on n'a pas encore peut-être
peut-être pas entendu parler aujourd'hui
mais c'est vrai que cette politique
politicienne comment ça commence à être
un supporter israélien
je pense qu'effectivement on cherche
maintenant plus du sens de la faune
cherche maintenant des nouvelles
personnes voilà je suis une lance le nom
de yossi cohen qui est le chef du mossad
qui semble peut-être être un candidat
qui va peut-être révolutionner les
choses s'annoncent sur rt france
peut-être que ça va être son arrivée en
toute heure où on suivra ça avec
attention et de près merci à vous anime
messika d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes analyste
politique